hey mom your son [ __ ] [ __ ] all over
himself out here in the park
[Music]
hello everyone hola mis amigos you're
listening to oh my god hi
with me george lopez
you know george is oh i'm sure he's
around here somewhere what's his name
george lopez george lopez oh my god omg
omg hi oh my god
hindsight is 20 20 and you can't change
the past
but what if you could get a little help
from your future self
maybe you'd ask to borrow a little cash
now you can with dave dave is a banking
app that can help you get up to 500
instantly with extra cash that's more
money to fill your tank buy a wedding
gift or catch up
on bills there is no interest and no
credit check
download dave from the app store now
that's d a
e
sign up for extra cash account and get
up to 500
instantly
instant transfer
fees
apply
this is a good question here we go
because you know
when
actors have to get emotional
or
when you are a detective or a nurse
or an emergency room doctor uh
a person on the street that that you
know
um
it's safe to say that most people
have not seen
someone either
die in front of them
someone either be on the verge of living
or dying in front of them
um i think i think you're the perfect
person to ask it's not anything like
it is on tv or it is in the movies right
that's right
or finding somebody it's not
i mean in the [ __ ] movies man
you can find
somebody that's been
you know in the beginning of csi
and then by 10 40 they find the body and
it still looks the same
it
it it does
how
i mean it's so many
how does how fast does the body
decompose
well the body goes through it depends
that is totally
uh dependent on the environment
the hotter the environment the quicker
it decomposes the colder the environment
the longer it lasts just like getting a
piece of meat leaving it out on your
on your front porch
and then letting it remember how garbage
uh cans used to stink you know you'd
open it up there'd be maggots and
everything well get that same piece of
meat put in your refrigerator
and it doesn't stink it doesn't
decompose as well so depending on the
environment
and uh
and
and
and you know uh
what's the word like being
not immune to it but you close off you
have to i mean
you know you
you're a detective or you're
a doctor
and someone
you know is brought in and
you know their guts could be hanging out
yes uh
you can't be a doctor and walk in and go
oh
oh jesus christ you know you're looking
to those people to be
they all have to be i don't think i mean
maybe they say to themselves but they
have to be professionals but
can you turn it on and off
yeah you know it becomes
i i can remember back my first dead body
that i rolled on as a homicide
investigator
and it was up in the mountains and it
was up laying in a creek there was still
snow around it so it was very well
preserved you know was it wasn't that
bad
so a few days later i went to the
autopsy now the body had laid out there
and then it got into the autopsy it was
refrigerated properly so now it's
starting to decompose
and i'm looking at this thing and i was
grossed out
and i'm looking at it
and the guy in the corners office back
then looked at me says eating an apple
he says
it's your first autopsy a kid
and
it was it was there
then i got used to it and like
everything else in life
what you do humor
it becomes a defense mechanism
so now you laugh at everything the
uglier the grosser it gets the more fun
you make of it not to dehumanize anybody
but that's how we as we get along and
then you get to the point where
it is no longer
blood guts and gore it's all very
scientific now you're looking like a
doctor for things that
the average cop wouldn't see the average
person wouldn't notice wouldn't know
what it is
so you start studying
and um
i think it's interesting you know i was
i was in the i was in the
car with uh
the actress and
i said to her
because you had to get emotional
that when you look back and you think of
the times that you were happy
um
like in a picture
if you look at a picture you can say oh
you guys look so happy
or when you think about being happy
it's a fleeting
it's a fleeting moment like it doesn't
stay
with you all day
or all week but if you think about
tragedy it's
it it weighs more than happiness way
more
that that's very true you just try and
de-personalize everything
you know the way i looked at it is this
way
babies
infants
now they haven't had time to say i love
you they haven't had time to jump on
your lap so it you didn't take those too
personal and then kids from the age of
12 to 13 started getting younger younger
the longer i got into business but 12 to
13
they've already had a little time to be
become a traviso so
it's it's not that bad but the kids in
between always got to me they always
bother me because
i had kids it's something that i could
relate to
and and so those bothered me they stood
with me for a long time
you just got to learn how to like
everything else push it aside
find something to laugh at it's
interesting because
like i think you know if you talk about
happiness and sadness and you talk about
man and woman
the what you know it's funny because you
know we use we use the like a feminine
term
to to demasculate somebody about it
there's a [ __ ]
you know you stop acting like a [ __ ]
uh
and you know uh
um
but in families where
a parent leaves it's always the man
not always but the majority of it it's
easy for the guy to leave and it's hard
for
women to
be the mother and father but they do it
you know grandparents do it
you know and and and parents do it and
women do it
and um
they
they have to assume the role of
of raising somebody when somebody who's
also could be responsible for that child
you know leaves you know
and um
[Music]
like
when i was when i was doing stuff with
like i still do it occasionally but i
did stuff with the children's hospital
and i would go over there
and i was seeing one
person
and then there was a girl who
was
who was dying
and um i went in there and she looked
you know hard like her skin looked hard
and her
movements were very hard you know like
you know very very tough like you know
it was tough for her to move
and her mom and her aunt were by the
side each side of the bed and i went in
there and she's you know talked a little
bit
and i said i'm gonna i had some t-shirts
and i don't think i had any and i said
you know i'm gonna have some brought
back
and
we went back and i think miguel took it
to the girl the girl had her mom and her
aunt and they
they held the shirt
and she passed
she passed that night
and um
you know you can't always like that was
just a good you know a good
moment where i got to see her she got to
be you know got to see me in it you know
um
but
in and females were there
and then there was like an i think maybe
the kid was like maybe eight from six to
eight
and he was in the room by himself
and
you know linda said hey you want to go
say hi to this kid
and
his father he had kidney disease like
and he was in the children's hospital
and his father found out that he was
sick and his father left left him left
the family
because the kid was sick
and
the kid is sick
and i sat next to him on the bed i took
a picture and that kid
was
let's say eight
and his eyes
were the saddest eyes that i've seen on
an adult
or
anybody
missing some dogs in the pound where
they look at you [ __ ] they're doing
their eyes like that because they want
to
[ __ ] go home with you
you know
it's like chicks in the bar the dogs
like you know they don't bark in the
shelter they [ __ ] give you their paw
that [ __ ] get them all to chew in
your [ __ ] couch [ __ ] guy in your
[ __ ] shoes
you know they just they just do enough
to get out but but uh uh and they know
what they're doing
and and the eyes on that kid man were
were
things that i think you know as sad as
that is
you know
you don't you know actors that become
either uh method actors or if you have
to act and get emotional you you have to
attach yourself to something
in sadness you know and it and it's
funny it just comes you know it kind of
it kind of it kind of comes so last
night it was really about
um my first friend that passed when i
found out you know because that was my
first friend and
and
and still very fresh in my in my mental
journey
yeah
yeah body shaking when i found out like
i don't body [ __ ] cry like i [ __ ] i
mean i made a book while you're crying
you know the the um
but
you know we we we're all
most people are pretty surprised when
someone dies but they shouldn't be
you know they always say like oh man i
just saw him but i mean
we all should treat people like it might
be the last time that you might see them
because it might be
sure you know i had a thing where
you know i was always kind of removed
and
i saw an actor at office depot one time
and i kind of hid from him and then he
passed away like two weeks later and
then it happened again and i was hiding
from people it's like
uh yeah i you know
i don't i don't really do that anymore
but um
in in this world of like you know uh
false
um false lives or
um
uh tick tock and instagram and twitter
and and and people who spend
most of their time being very negative
of other people like not me per se but
just negative you see it
or people that or people that post a
picture of their [ __ ] dog when you
come home and he's happy it's like
we've seen it already like if people
would just
if they had a filter to put down [ __ ]
that
didn't really mean anything a
chick with a fat ass you know on on
instagram it's like okay oh don't don't
stop those now let's keep going listen
man
if bad ass is like that at 23 what's it
gonna be at 43.
[ __ ] move the sofas out like you're
playing [ __ ] twister to get her in
the [ __ ] room
remember twister's or [ __ ] smell like
cocktails yeah yeah
i i know what you're talking about
that's how simple you got a kid with a
[ __ ] ipad and that [ __ ] is
like oh they got three bars [ __ ]
and then we would throw a piece of
plastic with some [ __ ]
dots of different colors and spin some
half cardboard with a yellow [ __ ]
dial my mother and we played for hours
twisting each other over each other so
you fell down i mean
we're where we're gonna end up i don't
i'm not sure
if we're gonna end up is gonna be the
best place for
for a society because
hateful hates all over there
you know um
people who uh believed that uh you know
elections were stolen or you're taking
rights away from from women
and people
and um you know we're still worried
about
how people
define themselves sexually it's like
we're in [ __ ] 2022 man this is some
[ __ ] that
you know if herm if [ __ ] the monsters
a [ __ ] [ __ ] frankenstein lived in
the neighborhood and everybody looked at
him and nobody tripped out
used to go to work he worked at the
funeral home
would take his lunch and he'd have a
[ __ ] hat on and nobody you know maybe
sometimes they'd be crossing the street
remember they would look and their
glasses would break
like you know
i i'm not the eternal optimist but all i
do is look at
the
brighter side of life i i i just have to
as you went to uh i went to city of hope
when i was a ring announcer for the
department in boxing the boxing team
went to the city of hope
and went in and got to visit some cancer
patients and cancer kids
and they're sad but my job there
is to try and make them smile do
anything i can and i could go out the
hallway and cry if i wanted to or feel
bad because i know they're not going to
make it
but
the gratification it gave me to put a
smile or give somebody a brief
bit of happiness
meant the whole
like it doesn't you know it doesn't mean
anything man
what i'm trying to say is people should
do things that mean something
because you and your [ __ ] dad and and
your mom
can do a trio
a dance on tick tock does not
a memory make
you know a tick tock
is not a memory it's a small video a
picture like if somebody says hey can i
take a picture with you and then it
stays in your phone it's not a picture
it's an image
a picture is something you can hold in
your hand
and you lose that phone you lose your
images but you never lost a picture
so you know nobody nobody's come up with
a better
nobody wants to print any pictures out
unless the you know it's on their they
put their [ __ ] levels on a copy
machine and try to close the lid you
know
what happened to this dude's eyes
somebody threw salt in it
all right so tell me what's going on at
the
uh [ __ ] uh coliseum of stephen
steakhouse
uh hey i was there last show
yeah i was there last sunday for a
brenton wood concert
uh what they've done with the outside
the city of commerce where they're
located
gave them permission they closed off the
street they turned it into a beautiful
outdoor venue
uh and there were the crowd was there
uh it was awesome
uh the owner of stevens who who's a good
friend of mine came up and we're
visiting he says hey
you want to introduce bretton wood
tonight
and so he actually let me get up on
stage and enter and introduce brett wood
who was the big big ticket the guy is 80
years old how many times did you have to
say it before he heard you
yeah
he was already up there i don't know if
you heard anything how does how does he
look he's got to be he was old when i
was on the radio 20 years ago
he looks old he looks weak they help him
get around everywhere but the guy gets
up in front of that microphone still
sounds good still puts on a show had
people going crazy
oh it was it was well worth the the show
uh i'm talking to uh i sent you some uh
pictures from the drone
the night before
uh they had some salsa group up there
the salsa night they did it they said
they had 4 000 people
and the group to put on
the entertainment for the night said
it was the best show that they had ever
taken part of some big so i don't know
anything about salsa especially post
pandemic matters i could get those many
people yeah did you feel safe there
yes i i did feel safe but i i did feel
safe you talk about from the pandemic or
from the body
i felt safe both ways because i was uh
seated in one of the cabanas but it was
it was nice i didn't get close to
anybody it was nice open air
uh no problems
those people that had to sit out in the
sun and it was sunny hot all day long
everybody's pissed down there it was
it was a tough day
uh they probably won't put on
another daytime concert uh
it was just too much it was too tough
but
nighttime concerts he's got him booked
do you think that people from the santa
fe spring swap me were were throwing
lemons up into the crowd or throwing
rocks oh i think everybody from santa fe
spring swapping was there all right you
know they they were there i mean the
whole water was there you could see
there was more spandex more chichudas
everything it was it was all there
latino i was the first thing i got there
i i got up on stage i said hey all right
are there any latinos in the house and
everybody said that's all there was
it was it was
now you're doing [ __ ] almost
everything
here's another one here's another one
you know uh body shaming
and body image
you know there's some people that
are
i mean i'm not gonna i'm not judging i'm
just saying
that maybe
the clothes that they're wearing
to the to the outside eye
may not be the most flattering clothes
to wear
but to the person wearing the clothes
they they don't think anything of it
where does that come from
i i think that just comes from cellos
you know uh imbedia the latinos are
known you know oh you know to make fun
of people or
to say i'm better than them
and and people that
those people who wear those clothes dude
talking about they don't care
they're
as long as they're happy within
themselves and they think they look sexy
they do to somebody they do
beauty's in the eye the beholder but in
the but in the 70s like like
the pants that guys wore or if you look
at some album covers
you know the guy's got a [ __ ] elote
in his pants so you know like they're
wearing the tight pants
and you know you could see the the
[ __ ] helmet line and all that [ __ ]
you know the but but nobody nobody
really does that anymore like the girl
like the women would the women wear
i'm not gonna say yoga because none of
them look like they do yoga i would say
um
i think tights is the right word because
they're [ __ ] tight
i don't even think it needs another ass
i just think it's like they were i'm
wearing tight
uh
and they're proud of it they're proud of
it they're they're male
partners that are with them being
boyfriend husband
anybody they're proud of their girls you
know they're it's like hey this is mine
and nobody cares
that nobody really really cares uh
because
it's their stuff hey it doesn't bother
me i don't care what anybody wears
i went to uh i went to take my friend
arnold uh to go see in anaheim years ago
kia san ted nugent
ted nugent open for open for kiss and
there was a guy in front of us
and he was
dancing in the same spot like just doing
his hips you know like like one went
like this
and that [ __ ] whipped up the
smell of cool oh man
i was looking i was you know i was going
like this
like where's it coming from i look at my
friend arnold he's like he he's like
this how did he ever he was like this
like
how do you have it like that
and he goes like this and the guy in
front of us was was just doing like a
stair master but his school was rubbing
against like that and this [ __ ]
had a bouquet of [ __ ] cuddle smell
right it's like a horse you get full
money inside of that thing oh my god man
i mean
because just he's just doing like that
you know it's just
rubbing up against it man
i stole the word from my friend george
lopez
last night don't ask me how we got
around to the conversation but on the
way home from dinner last night i'm
talking to my wife
and i asked her have you ever heard the
word
she's what's that
combination of bottom loader [ __ ]
[ __ ] plays about like
uh you know i think i think you know
the an app like dave
uh even if it's not 500 you know if it's
200 at 175 you know everybody kind of is
after the pandemic kind of going from
you know week to week month to month
whatever you know probably used up a lot
of their savings or people find it hard
to be in a pinch and um i think an app
like this um
will give you that kind of relief that
makes it easier to get to the next next
paycheck not much
but you know it it it just gets you to
the next to the next spot i think you
know um
you know when things uh
you know
phone bills or car payments or insurance
or um somebody getting sick or even
medicine even you know that it's good to
have uh
dave in your pocket and kick you down
some money so that
you can get what you need you don't have
to decide
what's important to you and then leave
something off right
dave is a banking app that can help you
get up to 500 instantly with the extra
cash that's more money to fill your tank
buy a wedding gift catch up on bills
you can finally tackle those expenses
that have been stressing you out without
any hangups there's no interest and
there's no credit check needed millions
of people have already downloaded the
dave app to get financial relief they
need with extra cash so if you're in a
pension you need some extra help
download dave and think of it as a
helping hand from future you you're
really kind of
taking from yourself and you're going to
pay yourself back and dave's the
middleman to make that happen download
the dave app from the app store right
now the d-a-v-e sign up for an extra
cash account and get up to 500 dollars
instantly
for terms and conditions go to dave.com
legal instant transfer fees apply
banking provided by evolve member
fdic you remember uh your future you
will thank you
so hey
aaron did you talk to that guy from the
hey did you talk to that guy
yeah he's in the waiting room right now
now let's bring this one
this gentleman
all right so i'm not even going to
explain what's going on because i
[ __ ] take too long talking
um
this this person
i've never seen her before
it's you can't even say male or female
anymore because you should be like hey i
you know i don't identify then you feel
like like you are like stuck in the past
uh
he's actually named paul he's borrowing
a laptop okay
who borrows a laptop this
[Laughter]
all right come on bring this dude in
[Laughter]
i'm gonna let him tell you himself i'm
not gonna [ __ ] i wish i wish him good
luck
wait till he tells you
and talk fast because we don't know when
rebecca needs her computer back
where is he
told him 10 30 so he might have stepped
away for a second
for three minutes
more quarters
i'm here i just don't know how to show
the video
[Laughter]
all right just tell us
where you go hey what's up guys
what's happening
hey how come you don't have your own
computer uh mine's just old it's just
not as quick as this one so i borrowed
one
uh how can it be you're [ __ ] 20 years
old how old can i
i wish i was 20 george i'm [ __ ] two
years old
you're 38 yes sir how about the hey
that's my [ __ ] there's my right here
goes to the park saying runs around like
trying to be young
i got to stay young my boy doesn't look
does he look young there's nothing
around the park he does
yeah he does
i drive around the park
following his past hey that that's that
guy's not young
all right so so explain to us
um
explain to gil how we met and to the
audience of what exactly uh you know
we're talking about well um
i hit up uh george through uh instagram
and um
i realized that
number one he's great
gil you know that um
he's got a lot going on he's got a lot
going for him right now and i was
thinking you know we've been listening
to this podcast me and my brother tony
um
we've been listening to this podcast
since it started and
i was thinking like we don't have a fan
club like why maybe we can create a fan
club or something where people this
that love this show can get together and
chat about it or have like a little
forum where we can talk and
get you know
some feedback from you and i had some
ideas about
you know maybe what it could be called
or how we could run it or you know some
ideas that we could do so that way you
can create more content and get more you
know viewers more listeners
and what do you what do you and your
brother like about the podcast because i
i try not to uh
i try not to analyze uh do you gil i try
not to analyze the podcast
no a lot of people have their opinions
say oh you got to do this you ought to
do that
and they're just they have no idea
what's going on
and maybe they haven't married yet
that's why you say that you get married
all you hear is [ __ ] do this and do
that
you're not wrong
let me get you a handyman and let me go
back to
upstairs all right go ahead uh the thing
that we love about it is is how freeform
it is you guys just roll with it
everything is is like off the seat of
our pants and it's beautiful you know we
it's it's like we're sitting with you
and gil and whoever is in the room and
we get to listen and we get to follow
along and you know laugh along and and i
mean sometimes we learn something a lot
of the times we learn something uh
different um life lessons or
experiences
and and stuff like that and and you know
i for one am a very big fan of that idea
like i think that
it's important for
uh
latinos and people of color to have to
to be seen and to know that we've got
representation to know that we got
people out here doing the things that
we've seen other people do our whole
lives you know and
um i think that's really what it is is
like
when we were growing up
i loved comedy growing up and from the
first time i saw george was probably on
latin kings of comedy
that like
it just immediately struck me like you
could have been the dude next door you
know you could have been the guy right
there
telling me stories you could have been
my uncle you know what i mean it was
just really cool to know that
uh somebody from l.a somebody from our
part of town
uh made it and did something cool and
and it was inspiring for us and you know
we just kind of want to pay back you
know whatever we can give back to the
inspiration that was given to us you
know you know i never really think about
any significance of of
of why or how i started doing comedy or
why i started or
how
you know
you know
doing the tonight show even in 91 or
being
on arsenio and all that stuff and then
doing the first show that's been on for
20 years you know as much as people
whine about uh
or whine or talk about or
or lament
about the lack of latinos on tv no one
seems to
give that show the credit that it
deserves
right
it's been on the air for 20 years and
hasn't been off since the beginning i
know you're talking about like seinfeld
talking about everybody loves raymond
you're talking about shows that are
uh of the best shows and situation
comedies and yet
the 20th anniversary came and went
without a [ __ ] article being written
about this [ __ ] and then you know you
have people trying to save one day at a
time which is a reboot
from another show and here's an original
show
and you get
i think maybe because the puerto rican
that you get
not sound like [ __ ] trump that that
that
that that
nobody's ever picked up the [ __ ] flag
to say hey how about this show
about a family that
happens to be latino that
it's not embarrassing to watch ever
and people still watch it every day it's
on tbs they're watching all over the
world and yet
and yet
nobody picks
nobody picks up the mantle
or the flag and wants to say how great
has it's been to watch this show
grow for 20 years and maybe it's me
maybe my politics or maybe the way i am
or maybe
you know i become a polarizing figure
but
i did it again 20 years later with my
biological daughter mayan nobody's done
that
and
i don't see [ __ ] bending over i
put it on instagram it's like five
thousand so you don't see anybody you
know
uh uh a [ __ ] guy
uh
is looking at a chick with glasses on
his girlfriend takes the glasses off
250 000 [ __ ] views and then something
that's good for the community and good
for the people it just goes ignored
yeah it's it's a
it's a weird thing like growing up and
watching movies about you know they had
latinos in them and everything like that
like
we we're always portrayed very weird
we're gangsters we're you know
criminals and and [ __ ] like that and
it's so cool like watching your show and
to tell you the truth like i'm i'm a
more i'm more of a fan of your stand-up
than i ever was of the show but only
because i didn't have cable and didn't
watch it when i was a kid you know i
actually got peacock just to watch the
show oh wow and
why would you have why would you have
cable going on a [ __ ] computer you
have cables
you can't see that can you i'm just
kidding
by the way i watched four episodes of
your show on the way back from chicago
on the plane they're playing it on a
plane
american airlines that's what's up
that's there you go that's exposure bro
that's hardcore stuff right there i was
on the plane one time with uh kevin
james and he was in uh first class and i
could see
that he was watching um
king of queens on
on the airplane and i thought and i was
that was in the 90s and i thought man
how great would it be to have a [ __ ]
sitcom that you can watch on a plane and
then there it is
there it is i'm telling you that i was
laughing you know i had earphones on but
i'm laughing it was it's a great stuff
all right so so uh what are you uh
how do you propose that we do this
i'm thinking we could do we could start
it with probably like an instagram page
that's just for fans and we could do
that i was thinking of um
there's this other podcast that i follow
it's uh it's called dungeons and daddies
and these guys have like a patreon page
where people like subscribe to your page
and then they like because they're
subscribers they get exclusive content
which we could do like you could do like
um
you could do like a live a live stream
like we could do on twitch uh get it get
a twitch channel and do your show in the
studio down there at all things comedy
and
like you know how when we're going
through the show and you're we're making
jokes and it's like hey if you've ever
dated a guy that's older you or a lady
that's older than you call in and then
you're like give us a call 85 you know
533. and
we always yeah i don't know the number
either but um i send my phone but
533 1843 that's right you know and um
so
we always say that but there's like not
necessarily a follow-up but what if we
had
the group of of uh followers
be able to
watch that twitch live stream and while
you guys are recording we could say if
that's you and the people in the
audience that have obviously paid to be
there can call in at that point and try
to get their opinions on but it would
only be fans because we would have
it set up to where you know you're
paying for it it's like a little five
dollar subscription or whatever but at
that point they get to be like possibly
on the show and to chime in with us or
with you guys i mean with us but i'll be
there watching but you know
um however we can make it that's just
one of the ideas that like we can
easily get something going where you can
have that conversation open almost like
a live radio show yeah
you know what did you open would you
open the twitch account
yeah i would i would start whatever you
needed you know we could work that out
and if there's you know any uh fees or
anything i can look into the
possibilities i have friends that are
video game streamers that would be able
to help me get that started and and
stuff like that is that a conflict aaron
no i don't think so i mean we could
start one obviously yeah you guys could
start when it's not a big deal like i'm
just bringing in ideas like i said um
this doesn't even have to be run by me
aaron can run it or anybody can run it
it's just the idea that
you know there are people out here that
love you and support you and would jump
at the chance to be able to you know
back you up like
we see you and mine sharing the things
about lopez versus lopez and we get
really really excited about that you
know that's that's another chance for
you to be out where you belong
where people can see you all right
you know i get it
uh what do you think gil
i just hope i don't get lost in the mix
you know i'm just
part of george
hey and if anybody has big that doesn't
they go to a [ __ ] excuse exclusively
[Laughter]
i like the idea jordan
it sounds good it sounds like more
exposure and it sounds like maybe the
possibility if we get something like
this out maybe we get that
what you're talking about
because when they did the documentary on
the night on the night stalker case
that's one of the things that started
off because
uh
there was no latinos there was no no
everything was
dope dealers
killers robbers you know
it was all negative so they wanted
some latino figure
to go ahead and put something positive
what he's talking about is just that and
then i think it's a great idea
did you go to a crime scene at a at a
wedding gill and and uh
identified the body but then took the
centerpiece home after
are you talking more
once people taking the centerpiece the
i'm
than
[ __ ] event hasn't even started yet
oh god yo go put this in the cart you're
like what you know
yeah all right yeah let's do it
okay unless we have uh we can have you
know
exclusive content and listen i got so
much [ __ ] in my garage i will get i will
even pull some
i'll give a guitar away i got a guitar
that i want to give away i'm sure we
could do some auctions for charities and
things that you support like your your
um the kidney disease one your
foundation yeah absolutely you know and
um
we could give you know some sanasana you
can do that and and you can you know
whatever we could do so many things the
the list is just so big like
i have
this idea that if it works out really
well you could do um
like you know like back in your in your
stand up you would do the you know now
you think you're out bad card or the uh
[ __ ] balloon you know how easy it how
easy it is to get those made nowadays
yeah and if you send a you ain't [ __ ]
balloon to somebody on their birthday
because they are in your fan club you
know what i mean with a little card i
like that you know what i'm saying like
for that material
gil
wait a minute wait a minute he better
not be chasing me out of my [ __ ] job
right now i'll tell you that right now
gil that is your job my boy we love you
your favorite thing
uh
it's probably not even yours balloon you
know yeah
even the um what about the like i had
this idea back when you were in vegas
and you were probably going to do the
i think you had an idea to go
and sell or deliver uh george lopez
tacos somewhere right of course yeah so
i so i used to be an uber driver and i
was going to hit you up and be like hey
bro like i'm going to be in vegas that
weekend too if you want let's just
get like a take a camera with us and go
and you and gail get to deliver to
somebody who ordered george lopez tacos
like how cool would that be especially
if they know that you know i mean it's
not always going to happen but it would
be fun to just outright surprise
somebody
and then there's a couple other ideas
that maybe we could talk about off the
air that are really good
you know what i'm saying but
remember how does it go
where they're going i got a new job they
go do they know you're a marijuana and
they go not yet then you go to the store
and you won't pull up somebody want to
know
[Laughter]
man attention
fill up some marijuana over
yeah
those are some good that was some great
ideas
yeah i've been thinking about it for a
while man you might not have a [ __ ]
computer but he might not need one it
has so much in his head we could do it
we could [ __ ] right here
maybe he'll be able to somebody will
donate one to one yeah you never know
you never know he's a young but how old
are you sid right 38 dude this
[ __ ] does not look like he's 38
yeah i know it's great right
he doesn't
be married
um
it's difficult
that's a yes or no answer brother
i'm getting divorced right now oh you
are
that's terrible i don't want to laugh at
you but that's not no no no hey it
happens you know
um but so that's why i was like that's
kind of a difficult situation but yeah
you know
would
sure i would get married again yeah
the right person came along
man i wouldn't get married
if my grandmother came out down from
[ __ ] heaven
i'd rather get my [ __ ] tip on my
[ __ ] beethoven card in my zipper
every day for five years
oh man that way when i go down the aisle
next time i'm not going to be walking
they'll be carrying me down that [ __ ]
aisle
yeah he'll be fighting
no they'll be popping a [ __ ] caja in
the box say that don't be trying to put
no [ __ ] ring on me when i'm dead
if i pull one out for eternity i put
this on if i could go in there they dig
me up and the ring is gone
they don't want the [ __ ] ring on
no something
some do i don't know man i think you
know some people have like guild's been
married for 51 years i i
i think maybe
like i never saw any relationships that
worked growing up
in my own family so i think all those
things
uh
play into it like i don't have any baby
pictures of me
growing up i mean
the [ __ ] hitler has [ __ ] baby
pictures man and yeah
he's like what the [ __ ]
anybody who says
shorts and not even me anybody who says
marriage is easy has never been married
yeah that's for sure
but
yeah
do you and your wife do you and pearl uh
call each other like mom and dad mom oh
that hey papa
papa and nava
because
hey dad
uh uh
oh no she said mom i'll be out here
and then uh i said hey mom your son
[ __ ] [ __ ] all over himself probably
in the park
[Music]
she knows my wife you're almost trying
to clean this cooler
with the water where people drink water
that's for everybody
pearl doesn't give me and she always
calls me papa now
and when i'm not in the best of moods i
just hey pearl
you know i call her by her first name
you know
but all the kids that grew up with my
kids that are now in their 40s
uh late 40s they all call papa gill not
a pearl my grandkids
donna and papa
and it's just the name you know what
about when people go to sleep and they
got those sleep machines on both of them
with the [ __ ] thing
the cpap i said you walk into the room
and look like about [ __ ] where they
test
makeup on animals whether they're
[ __ ] two people
i'll go in there and step on your
[ __ ] holes like in the middle of my
life
yo george i had a i had a question um i
read your book that's on audible we we
did the one the one where you when you
were turning 50.
how did you read it oh i heard it well i
heard it yeah yeah that's right gil
that's what i meant um
i got through that book though and do
you have one for your first
for your first book that you wrote
the one where you told your life story
you know what that's a very good
question you know
i
um
had the studio booked you know and i
think i was doing it i was going to try
to do it at night
because i think i was doing the show
during the day and those things are not
easy to do man because you have to get
the diction right right and there's
there's a pay scene and there's a
director for for recording books the one
the one that i end up doing the guy
was a director that does a lot of books
and i
i [ __ ] bitched about we did it over a
weekend
and i really never complain about
anything else but man i was such a pain
in the ass that week because i was like
dude man this is just [ __ ] killing me
man i couldn't do it
because i just it just
it was just more
monotonous or it just was more annoying
to me
than to do it but the first one
um
man
the first one i go in there
and i start to read the first page
and the first page is tough
start to read the second page after the
third page
and in there i can't remember how many
pages but early on this book was like
250 pages maybe
i got into like four or five pages and i
stopped and i was like um
i told those dudes hey man
i can't do this like what do you mean
i said i i um
i can't read this book
um
it's just too it's too emotional for i
can't read it
i can't read it and and i would break
down you know i would start to tear up
and it's like i
the things that were you know when
you're saying them to a writer like arma
container is great he's on real sports
he's on cbs one of the best
uh writers
and he was just amazing because he went
with me for a year and a half or so and
when you're telling him you're telling
them and it's kind of going out and
you're leaving it out and then when you
see it written
i couldn't get through the first
10 pages i wasn't going to get through
the book i mean i was not going to get
to the book
and i remember i saw a guy at a book
saying he was uh
sight impaired and he said you know i
looked i i look forward to hearing the
story if anything i still remember that
guy saying uh i look forward to hearing
the the book on tape
and i never did it
no i understand that though that that's
it was too emotional and then i said why
don't you just get somebody to do it and
they were like no they they prefer that
it being your
in your voice but the first one was on
the it was like it was number five on
the
new york times bestseller list yeah um
and uh
yeah it's interesting man because um
i don't think i could even do it now if
they said oh yeah it's a good idea to go
back and maybe do it after
20 years or
yeah it's probably about 20 years now
yeah
yeah you know i've never read i'm not a
reader and i've never even read the book
on the night stalker case yeah i just
don't read it it's got a bunch of
pictures i like them i'm easy i'm lazy
the books
where the word i never heard about your
book i never knew about your book i
became friends with you and i i didn't
know but i'd like to read the first book
about you
yeah whether in your voice or not i'd
actually read it
it's pretty sad
yeah i bet man life is hard
you know yeah it's pretty telling it's
even harder
yeah man i mean italian it is
yeah yeah i it's it's
it's it's you tell it i'll find
something to laugh at yeah i mean both
of us it's funny there's not some funny
stuff in there but it's just you know
it's uh
i get it dude i get it a lot
because i was thinking maybe that could
be a thing for the patreon but if it's
already all right for the patreon you
know what hey you know what maybe maybe
exclusive members only uh for the
patreon i would read the book for
patreon members oh no [ __ ] all right
i was also thinking that you could like
live journal since then
like where you would just tell like okay
for the last like let's say up to when
it when it was done
you can go okay between these five years
this is what happened and kind of write
a new chapter
and you know and then that could be like
a stretch goal we get so many like 100
people or 500 people then we can you
know george will do a new a new uh
chapter
for his book you know
you gotta tell the story on how you met
the fat [ __ ] gave him a free hat
now you can't get rid of him
uh
yeah i you know when when my publicist
said have you seen the night stalker
documentary and you know that's right in
my house i already seen that thing four
times
and i was like man how come i didn't
know this dude man like i said i gotta i
gotta know this guy what am i doing over
here um but um
how i got into true crime and all that
stuff you know ghosts and yoronas and
all that [ __ ] that's that's natural
that's like that's like air conditioning
basic it's basic [ __ ] equipment uh
uh but uh
crime
and you know having manson be a fan
a
as gotcha as it is is very
i mean
i mean a lot of comedians that can say
that charles manson was a fan of theirs
i mean that guy that wrote the last book
on him
[ __ ] said hey how do you spend your
time i listen to classic rock of course
he liked rock music he was a singer
guitar player and then uh he's like i
love john wayne frank sinatra and george
lopez and the guy sent the quote to my
manager and he goes show this to george
[ __ ] charles manson
i think that's badass
me too yeah me too look at charles
manson's a fan of yours
not every day somebody makes a murderous
night table you know what i'm saying
it's pretty crazy also speaking at night
table you can always tell how old
someone is by the [ __ ] they have on the
side of their bed
what do you got when you're young you
probably got a [ __ ] pencil there you
got i got [ __ ] febreze and a
[ __ ] ointment
[ __ ] some [ __ ] i mean [ __ ]
medicine that's a mango over there
[ __ ] it i mean it's just like what the
[ __ ] is this it's almost like a [ __ ]
thrift sale on the [ __ ] side of my
bed over here
man that's right
yeah you got a quarter with cvs right
there you're going we'll get it we'll
get updates and then you can update us
on on uh that'll be good we'll get you
you have aaron's email yeah i do uh
let's see if we can make it interesting
for people yeah we can even like
uh
i mean i i used to teach guitar i know i
think i've talked to you about that
we've talked about terry cat
your relationship with uh
uh eddie and um maybe we could you know
jam one day and just i could you know
break down a piece of the music that you
want you know maybe that's difficult and
having been a guitar teacher how did you
learn how to how to uh play the guitar
you know it just kind of came naturally
to me i i didn't i don't understand it
really
uh my uncle larry was a guitar player
and he had a guitar when i was a kid and
i was just always intrigued and he gave
me my first guitar but like just
it was like a fish to water like it you
you know
just
immediately became something that i was
good at and i couldn't understand why
and and uh i taught myself like it was
really weird like i would listen to the
music
and
my ear was able to
like kind of match notes with whatever
was on the guitar and then i'd start to
okay cool these guys
you know wrote it so they can play it so
it's probably not incredibly difficult
because they've got to remember it so
starting to you break that part down you
start to think okay well how does this
logically make sense then you start to
create the pattern you start to recreate
it and practice it then it becomes
something that you know you start to
have on you know under your belt so okay
so here's a guy
that
never had an album
never had gold
platinum or any hit singles
and what you said about it being easy is
what eddie said to me about it when he
played when he played in front of me i
said i said how do you remember that
[ __ ] he's like it's easy
and i'm like easy he goes yeah it's easy
when you know the formula
because we have to play it night after
night why would i want to make
something difficult
to be able to play night after night he
goes it's easy hell yeah that's exactly
what i was thinking
i mean you think i like that he never
wanted to give any credit to anybody but
there's a little like a little 14 year
old girl and she was playing eruption so
one morning we're playing golf and i get
on youtube and we're watching eruption
and he comes over and he's like hey let
you guys
this guy's looking at it's like oh check
this out it's like a 14 year old girl
that's playing eruption he was looking
at it
and when he was done he just walked away
you know and i said hey she's 14
and he goes i wrote it when i was 12.
you know it's like
you can't
you know you're never going to chop
you're never going to [ __ ] top
a music they've never given up i said
like that was the [ __ ] i laughed so
[ __ ] hard uh i wrote it when i was
she's 14 man when i was 12. that's it
like people don't you know they don't
want to give it up like like uh well uh
the guy uh this guy ken corday me and
dad had just played and that guy was
there and i said to ken hey ken
you know he played drums in a band that
opened for jimi hendrix at the at the at
the hollywood bowl nice and i said hey
uh ken you know mr van halen
and i said uh and he goes hey mr
maddalen the
second greatest guitar player in the
world and i was like oh no
did he suck him because he should have
sucked like all right all right and he's
like who's number one
and he goes uh hendricks and goes yeah
if you like your [ __ ] rock out of
tune
oh no
i said did he play out of tune he goes
[ __ ] ass i'm [ __ ] i was out of tune
all wobbly and [ __ ]
and you're just like you know i'm like
all right guys all right like breaking
up two [ __ ] dogs yeah all right all
right all right
yeah you have to fight that you have to
fight that instinct when somebody would
say you know who's funny this person is
you just be like uh
yeah
yeah man what kind of guitar you got
there george what is that is that one
that that ed gave me the first one oh
[ __ ]
that's cherry bro it's beautiful
beautiful beautiful
yeah
yeah let's do that let's do that and see
if we can't uh
you know
fill in the
fill in the blanks here gil what do you
think
i think i'm all for it george it sounds
good he got so many bright ideas he's
young he's enthusiastic i think
everything's there it's going to give us
more exposure it's going to give
the
jordan lopez oh my god hi more exposure
give you more exposure i think we should
do our own social media i think we
should do our own crime con too
that'd be fun do it
whatever whatever you want to do
you know i'm just
this is this is truly
part of the probably the best part of my
life i mean i'm i'm old you know i'm
doing this everything's going well
uh the way we hooked up the way things
are going i'm i'm just lucky man i'm in
for the ride brother whatever you want
yeah all right
let's go all right dude we'll have aaron
uh get with you and then uh we'll check
back in a couple weeks and let's see
what uh yeah hey george before we go um
my my best friend tony he was who got me
into this when we first started i was
gonna call in last year and be like hey
george can you
call tony and tell him happy birthday
his birthday is on the 23rd
and i was just wondering if you could
just shout out tony and just tell him
happy birthday for me how old is he
he's going to be 32 what is 90 yeah 32.
all right
hey tony happy birthday man 32 years i'm
wasting your [ __ ] time get your [ __ ]
together
and make the next 32 better than the
first 32 [ __ ] king
that's not me talking that's your mom
[Laughter]
all i can say is ditto
yeah that's it hey happy birthday to you
happy birthday probably yeah his
birthday would probably come around
around his birthday too the 23rd right
somewhere around there
yeah i bought heroin in downtown l.a one
time by mistake
i just realized that
what's the statute of limitations
you got any change i
that's what a guy did i bought heroin
without knowing him
alleged oh
alleged alleged alleged bad to say
yeah those are good stories all right
yeah right on man let's see
okay we're good
all right am i right on thank you thank
you for the thank you for your interest
yeah for sure man let's do this and it's
always dudes it's never vienna hey
too busy all right
yeah
they don't want me
all right aaron uh all right good
we'll start to
finish up here hey can you do phone
calls erin
uh no we can't take phone calls on doom
no i mean can you place them back
uh
i don't know where grant keeps those
[ __ ]
[ __ ] see that's what happens
they
you know
that's what happens when you wait when
you give power to the dude that you know
that
the second the whole [ __ ] assembly
line stops
all right but that's good we we're good
for today you know
whatev
you're good i'm good brother thanks
rebecca for uh letting her use your
computer yeah for sure
i got bernie questioned me
is rebecca part of why you're going
through your divorce
no comment no no comment
that's all that's awesome okay
thank rebecca
all right
it's all shiny and new too you see one
of the tongues laid out
i'm not a [ __ ] dancer
how did that get in there that's what i
want to know
all right fellas i'll catch you guys
next time we'll see you soon peace
out
you can see but on lady not it's not
attractive
you